hiya British and guten tag welcome back
America merica to the fruity pasture now
hows it going bros mate
today we're gonna play three free games
oh yeah yeah it's the show we're
prototype place a bunch of shitty video
games it's fun all right geez quiet you
have to be so [ __ ] negative first
game is called omnibus this game is in
very early development and it looks
[ __ ] awesome and yeah oh my god well
if you're not sold already then I don't
know what the [ __ ] your problem is mr.
buzz sir bus ultra bus which one one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
why did I do it like that only the lid
off kick Ilana cough cough Ilana big
about it Allah dhul it off sir bus it is
alright so [ __ ] yeah six-drink brunt is
that it let's try that again
with mr. bus I did it oh there's a ramp
whoo oh my god two sprays me Pepe all
barrel roll we're entering corneria city
now
you're becoming more like your father
two sprays where will Oh God
I like the music is nice whoa do another
jump yeah a spin reversal whoa
not everyone knows how to do that [ __ ]
aha
driving way too slow okay mission mode
the bad kids
yo omnibus we hate that statue in the
park and wanna pull a prank knock off
his head what the [ __ ] is it's part
Simpson oh my god you can't just start a
level like that oh my god how do I knock
off its head here we go whoa no oh my
god stop you're being ridiculous Romney
bus okay we're we keep going okay no no
Donna stay strong Omnibus yeah whoa all
right we got enough speed
let's do Deus never mind [ __ ] sake
how do you can you can't control the
Omnibus the Omnibus will devour is our
yeah
yeah that's what I'm talking about
take that statue thanks MD piss amazing
oh my god okay let's do the loop never
mind then we're not doing the loop
apparently yes I always wanted to play a
game where I play as a buzz who can do
skateboard tricks you thought I was a
bus no of a snake yeah yeah whoo oh god
that's yeah
oh god this thing is impossible to
control seriously what the hell come on
damn it nap near ass wonderful a
beautiful little game but we have two
other march' plays so let's get into it
shall we not do it
the next game is probably one of the
greatest game of our generation people
in the future people will go back and
look at this game and say this is a
pinnacle point for the human race
it's called shower game it's a game
about taking a shower
yes ah so nice I'm so glad I can relive
this if you for experience inside a
video game oh there's my sexy body
alright I know you can crouch in this
game unless there it is and there's a
poop did I just squeeze you out
hi pod I love you is there someone by
the window what the [ __ ] poop no damn
you society a squeeze out another one
okay alright alright I'm like a
chocolate factory you know it's okay to
poop in the shower my god stop yet why
don't you take a picture it's okay to
poop in the shower because it's good for
the environment oh my god how many of
these chocolate bunnies can I lit out I
don't know why but I remember at one
time someone's friend had a party and
then he pooped in the bathtub and then
he was playing with his poop that was
not me what where's her blood everywhere
oh my god what happened to my skin oh
the [ __ ] ah yeah no oh my penis is
out what the [ __ ] I'm so confused don't
let don't don't so childish
what the [ __ ] is this diamond [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that I eat what the [ __ ] has
happened
it gives me hair oh my God look at my
beautiful haircut
fabulous Oh
everything I touched becomes gold even
my [ __ ] please even my [ __ ] oh my god
they're gold and Dukey I'm such super
long alright alright alright alright
alright alright alright
ten out of ten best game ever won't you
agree
oh my god
Oh Oh okay press up start wrecking
nailed it whoo
oh [ __ ] me Oh nah
I came in like a uh I don't know
Oh God what is that is that an upgrade
Wow oh my gosh
what is going on help help
this is for not paying a read oh my god
I'm so bad oh my god
oh my god
no I do not have a mental challenge
ability or whether whatever the I can't
speak alright maybe that's my problem
that's right [ __ ]
that's how we doing it I put a pat down
yay well this is my laughs this is what
I do
oh god I'll [ __ ] me then yeah alright
what I'm so bad please please my the
[ __ ] you you get your shop um Bruce
that was sit for three free games for
Pierce you can check all these games out
in the description a shower game let's
see if it takes over the world will it
just gonna happen
leave a like enjoyed this episode I had
a lot of fun playing with you as always
all greatest game of all time we found
it kindly read a game that I generated
in left not a 10 that's quite impressive
I can't believe it after all these games